OK, let's get back to the phones via discord
at David Pakman dotcom discord and hear from
some folks who want to get in.
Let's go next to let's go to Bart from California,
Bart from California.
What's going on?
Bart from California, you were on, but you
must unmuted yourself.
I'm here, how are you, David?
Good.
How are you?
I'm doing.
I'm doing well.
We're still in covid land.
And fortunately, we're in even in California,
we're suffering pretty much, but we're safe
at the moment.
Fairly safe.
So that's good.
Good.
I had to you know, by way, I love your show.
I listen to it every, you know, every day.
It's just a wonderful show.
And you have it's great intellectual discussion.
And I'm just really pleased with the content.
Thank you.
Absolutely.
Mike, my question is about the about the Electoral
College, what I'm here's my premise.
It seems like we're being held hostage essentially
to the Electoral College in the sense that
as people leave the Midwest, the young people
leave and go to perhaps California and New
York and different places that are more, you
know, progressive is sort of a distillation
process that ends up causing basically us
to be more and more conservatively strapped,
essentially.
And I just wanted to get your take on that
which and how can we basically get rid of
the Electoral College?
Well, so it's a two part question.
First, yes, you're absolutely right that I
mean, listen, any one vote has a different
amount of power in in one state versus another.
If you move as a as a as a Democratic leaning
voter, if you move from Florida to California,
the likelihood that your vote will impact
the election results has gone down dramatically.
You still get one vote on paper, right?
It's one vote either way.
Yeah, but it's very unlikely that your vote
will make a difference in California.
While it was much more likely it would make
a difference, you know, you could say North
Carolina, Georgia, whatever.
So that's absolutely true.
And Republicans know this.
Republicans benefit from it.
Republicans very frequently lose the popular
vote and have won the presidency.
I believe I saw today that it's been in the
last eight elections.
Republicans only got forty eight percent of
the popular vote.
I believe it's one time something like I mean,
it's crazy.
Now, how do you get rid of the Electoral College?
Because so many states are run by Republicans
and Republicans know they benefit from the
Electoral College.
You're not going to do it via a constitutional
amendment.
I think the most direct path is the national
popular vote interstate compact, by which
states can decide to award their electoral
votes, not to the winner of their state, but
to the winner of the popular vote nationally.
If enough states do that, you have a sort
of de facto popular vote and they have a website
and you can learn a lot more about it.
That sounds great now that's what I was thinking,
it would be very difficult.
And by the way, this came up when I was talking
to when I was phone banking, providing a person
know Ohio is telling me this, the time people
are leaving Ohio because they just no jobs.
Right.
They're just leaving.
And that also, you know, what's interesting
about that part is it goes to the importance
of job creation in those states because it
can help people, particularly young people,
who are more likely if they enter the workforce
in that state, they are more likely to stay.
We know young people are more likely to vote
for Democrats.
Job creation can be a big campaign strategy
in practice.
Yeah, actually, with the covid situation,
a lot of remote working, which I like Hawaii,
for example, I heard is now trying to attract
people to live there.
Yeah, maybe this is a good time to attract
people back to the Midwest with can you can
work remotely.
Right, Beth?
Perfect idea.
That's actually really all I had I was just
just wondering about that particular topic.
I wish there was a way to get rid of Mitch
McConnell.
I mean, that that person seems like such an
evil man that I just can't believe he basically
controls the fate of millions of Americans.
I wish there was a way to shift tens of millions,
even listen to him to reshape the call.
Thank you so much.
Absolutely.
Have a great day, David.
All right.
There's Bart from California.
Very, very strong call.